so uh i guess
a million questions but um
what was it actually about this story
and project that said oh i need to do
this
well
um many reasons you know it's it's it's
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity for a
pretty an experienced director to be
offered that kind of job
for a story that is so i mean i cried
when i read the script and it was so
moving for me
that relationship
between ruth and katie you know the
whole theme about unconditional love and
i have a sister myself i would do
anything for her and
what would you do for family
oh completely one one of the things
about this film is stories like this are
are much tougher to get made nowadays
and i think that you know credit to
netflix for making it and telling this
story
you know um so i just want to throw that
out there big thank you to netflix um
obviously you haven't worked with sandra
before um she is what we call a talented
actor what was what are some of the
things that really surprised you about
collaborating with her
well
first of all how approachable and
grounded she is i mean given
her status and her experience you know
um
i think from the from the get-go we made
on we met on an eye to eye level and she
is also producer on that film so she
accompanied me in my process from the
very first day until the very last day
and it was always you know um
the question of what's the best choice
for the story that we want to tell here
and for ruth's character and there is
everything nothing is random you know
until like the
black scratched nail polish a root that
she had in her flashbacks like so many
thoughts we put into everything there
was just an amazing process
i like talking to directors about
editing because that's where the movie
comes together
this is one of those films where you
have flashbacks you have
different timelines if you will talk a
little bit about the the editing and you
know the challenges that you faced once
you got in the editing room to tell the
story without giving away too much at
points
and and there you are already with the
biggest challenge you know how much can
we withhold without losing interest
and how much do we need to tell you know
in order to make sense and how do we
balance all those different characters
without being confusing
i think that is something you know that
that accompanied us
through through every um version of the
edit it's almost like jenga or tetris
when you you know take away on that side
or you give too much here an hour later
everything falls apart um and
and yeah it was it was fascinating it
was trial and error and in the end i
think we found the right balance
100 um did you originally have a much
longer cut um how like did you have a
cut that was like two and a half hours
you're like i don't know how we're
getting it any shorter
well not much longer to be honest i
think we started off with the
two hour ten you know so we lost 20
minutes in the process but there were
many moving pain pieces that you know
some scenes that are now in the film
that weren't there at all and other
scenes that were in there are now
completely out so it shifted around
quite a bit
um what ended up being let me say it
like this if you could go back to the
first day of filming on the making of
this movie what would you tell yourself
what advice would you give
yourself relax
enjoy the ride
right
i'm sure it was a was it stressful for
you though because making like a big
movie like this with sandra or did you
sort of get to enjoy it
um both you know i mean it's i think
directing is always overwhelming you you
there there is always the time when you
think like oh god i think somebody else
should do that you know it's it's a
constant and probably for all
departments i think it's an artistic
thing then
you you feel almost like you have a big
grizzly bear behind you breathing in
your neck
that says like
other people could do that much better
wait and see until they find out and you
have to learn and live with that bear
and um
and i think sometimes you know
it's it's easier to just chill out and
enjoy the ride because i i i was
supported by so many great people all
along the way
it was magical
one of the things is your film got shut
down because of covid and i've spoken to
a lot of filmmakers and they actually
talk about how having a break in the
middle of shooting is is really
beneficial because you can look at your
footage you can reassess everything how
did that shutdown possibly change the
movie because you had more time to
really think about everything
i mean like you said we edited what we
had and of course it was a very
fractured cut you know missing a
beginning missing and ending but we
could see what works well and what does
not work quite so well and we adjusted
the script according to that
um
of course it's always challenging you
know to film half a film in winter and
then the second half and summer and make
it fit together you know so you have to
put an extra effort into everything also
to bring the energy back up
but yeah it's just definitely it's a
silver lining and there were some great
benefits that we had
was there any one particular thing that
you took out or added that maybe would
surprise fans to learn
yeah for example the welland brothers
um before kova they didn't have a mom
oh
that is a big change
okay i'm thinking about i'm playing that
all in my brain now and what it would
have been without that but
what ended up being when you look back
what was the sequence that really ended
up being like a just a real pain in the
ass you know the thing that just was you
know in on the shoot
um i mean there are scenes that didn't
end up in the film you know for for
probably a good reason because for some
reason or the others we didn't really
um get to the best version of the film
and in the end the best version of the
film is without that scene
completely no completely um are you
already thinking about what you might
want to do next have you had time to
even digest that yeah not yet i just had
a baby
and now taking it easy for a little
while
um i completely understand uh um my last
thing for you uh sandra doesn't talk
that much in the movie it's very
deliberate when she speaks can you sort
of talk about balancing that like did
you end up pulling back even more of the
dialogue like finding her voice if you
will
yes absolutely it was um we always
set off to start the journey with her
being as close as possible and then
almost having that two-hour process of
witnessing her slowly open up
um
and in the edit again you know it was a
balance of
how
long are we as the audience willing to
go with her
although she doesn't speak and um saying
thanks to sandy's eyes you know there is
such a rich inner life
and then we added the memory layer as
well to give a little hint that there is
something warmer inside her as well you
know and there is something
that connects her with katie and that
kept her alive all the time inside
so
um i have to stop there i'm just gonna
say congrats on the movie and uh after
you have time with the baby i hope
you're making something again soon thank
you